the Xbox one has slowly come into its
own this year with a strong games line
up throughout 2015 several of these
titles are available on other platforms
but nevertheless they help bolster
Microsoft's lineup and as 2015 comes to
a close Xbox one owners have access to
excellent sequels immersive RPGs and
fine-tuned platformers Ori and the blind
forest is one such game on the surface
it's vibrant color palette and detailed
2d world art gorgeous beneath its beauty
though Ori is a brutal platformer with
fluid controls and a sense of precision
it also uses a Metroidvania design that
sweeps you along as newfound abilities
grant access to secret areas this makes
exploration a key aspect of the
platformers appeal or in the blind
forest is gorgeous but through its
mechanics and engaging overall design it
is also cemented itself as one of the
best xbox one releases this year then
came the witcher 3 wild hunt many rpgs
present massive worlds with secrets
worth finding but CD projekt red's
newest title places us in a world rife
with deep stories despite its grand
ambition the witcher 3 is at its most
powerful when it narrows its focus on
characters we follow gareth of rivia
through swamps into dark alleyways and
across massive plains developing
relationships with other people their
characters worth listening to and as the
credits close it's how we interact with
them and how those interactions shape
the northern kingdoms that leaves a
lasting effect this RPG does have
experience gains and gear discovery but
it's the writing and the stories we
stumble on that make it an exceptional
game in Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom
pain series creator Hideo Kojima uses
melodrama to delve into themes such as
loss betrayal and nationalism asking us
what it means to be a part of the human
race we trek through the expanses of
Afghanistan and Africa and the shadows
rescuing prisoners and extracting Intel
before the enemy knows we're there metal
gear solid 5 layered mechanics create a
world in which we're always working
toward a goal whether it be new
equipment new allies or the means to
expand our home base
in the end though the phantom pain
excels because it reminds us that
everything is fleeting and we could be
moments away from losing it all fallout
4 is inhabitants on the other hand
already know that they wake each day to
a decaying world and pale son eking out
a living amidst the post nuclear waste
of Boston Massachusetts but that's the
story is one of moral choices and in
this world survival often means for
getting your principles fallout 4 is
superb not just because it's exciting
exploration based gameplay but because
that gameplay aligns with the setting we
roam its waist form Alliance and
scavenge for materials in the interest
of staying alive its crafting is superb
and deciding where to go next is half
the appeal of this game not just which
weapons to use or what armor to wear but
whether we would sacrifice our friends
for the good of the human race this
brings us to rise of the Tomb Raider a
game also steeped in moral ambiguity
Lara Croft is a video game icon but
developer Crystal Dynamics molds are
here to great effect in a story where
people's motives aren't as initially
seen on a gameplay level rise of the
tomb Raider's refined mechanics feel
superb and the pacing creates momentum
throughout the entire game exploration
leads to resources which lead to new
equipment which leads to new secrets in
previous areas then we have the titular
tombs which has some of the more clever
puzzles this year and like everything
else and rise of the Tomb Raider they're
worth doing and they're just fun as
their completion leaves two items in
make Lara's Trek easier in short rise of
the Tomb Raider is an excellent
action-adventure game with almost no
added weight and is propelled by a great
story in a gorgeous detailed world 2015
was a great year for games across every
platform and the Xbox one also reap the
benefits it served as a home for one of
the year's best platformers it played
host some of the best open-world games
ever made Microsoft's console has come
into its own all thanks to a stellar
line-up of games and it inspires
optimism as we head into 2016
you
you